it one of the problems that Kanye has  been having is the same as a similar  problem the way Hitler was having which  is that some people were screwing with  him and they were Jewish so he blamed  the entire Jewish religion I had to say  this and I hope this doesn't get me in  trouble though but it does prove Kanye a  little right as soon as they take away  his bank account I mean you know I mean  but it's this is the problem  because what's happening is like you had  30 dogs and 29 of them were Brown it  doesn't mean that most dogs are brown no  what what country is saying is abharan  disgusting but it's just you know you  know him getting shut down I now it's  like I think he's doubling down the the  Trump where now he can't go back and be  like oh I didn't mean this I meant you  know there's just these few guys that's  what I'm I think it's it's slope he's  just gone too far